Gibt es nicht ökonomische Gründe, das zu machen?
Nein.
Gut. Dann sprechen wir gleich in der nächsten Stunde darüber, was denn jetzt eigentlich mit dem Glasfaserausbau ist und wie wir da hinkommen. Keegan Whitney, The Castle's All Alone von The Differences Album. Kann man sich kostenlos runterladen und weitergeben, ist Creative Commons Musik und das bedeutet, ihr seid im Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Und dort reden wir heute darüber, wie wir vielleicht alle mal möglichst breitbandiges, möglichst schnelles Internet zu uns nach Hause bekommen können. Und dafür begrüße ich zurück den Johannes, den Stefan, den Filz in den Mutagshalonen. So, wir haben also quasi den Point of No Return unterschritten. Ich kann euch jetzt die erste Stunde nicht mehr in einem Satz zusammenfassen, aber kann kurz sagen, wir haben festgestellt, wir brauchen mehr Internet zu Hause. Und das geht nicht mit dem Kupferkabel, was über das ihr normales DSL bekommt, sondern dafür will man eigentlich Glasfaserkabel haben, weil die schnelleres und mehr und besseres Internet machen. Und wollen jetzt mal darüber sprechen, warum das nicht so passiert, wie man sich das vorstellt. Und da würde ich sozusagen noch einen fünften Gast mit ins Boot holen. Ich habe das vor der Sendung kurz mit ihm gesprochen, nämlich mit Heiko Liebscher von Wilhelm Tell. Das kann er eigentlich gleich selber erzählen. Es geht darum, wie ist das denn eigentlich, wenn man den Plan hat, Glasfaser überhören zu bringen, was passiert denn da? Und ich habe den Heiko Liebscher erst mal gefragt. Wilhelm Tell, erklär doch mal bitte genau, was ist denn das?
Ja, Wilhelm Tell ist ein kleiner Seeking-Netzbetreiber, der 1999 gegründet wurde, befindet sich im Norden von Hamburg, hat eine ganze Stadt, also 32.000 Haushalte, mit Glasfaser versorgt, schon 1999, baut dementsprechend viel aus und hat jetzt auch 200.000 Anschlüsse in Hamburg rein mit Glasfaser bis zum Kunden.
Was für, über welche Bandbreiten sprechen wir da?
Ja, also wir sind ja mal ganz am Anfang gestartet mit 10 Megabit, dann 100 Megabit und inzwischen sind wir tatsächlich so, dass wir über die Glasfaser, über den Medienkonverter Gigabit haben. Zurzeit wird das Produkt als 250 Megabit-Produkt vermarktet, wird aber in diesem Jahr halt als Option dann auch bis zum Gigabit angeboten werden.
Ich will jetzt sozusagen nicht über genaue Preise sprechen, weil es keine Werbeveranstaltung werden soll, aber nur wissen, wenn man das sich als jemand als Privatperson holt, dann spielt sich das, ich sag mal, im üblichen Rahmen ab.
Also das ist in einem üblichen Rahmen, wo wir sonst eher mit einem 100 Megabit-Anschluss rechnen. Also, wer unsere Preise kennt, der weiß, dass wir also marktgerechte Preise haben, sonst kann man natürlich in diesem großen Wettbewerb nicht bestehen, aber selbstverständlich kann sich das eine Privatperson leisten.
Also die sind sozusagen, ich sag mal, normal bezahlbar. Warum gibt sie nicht schon überall diese Anschlüsse?
Ja, das liegt teilweise daran, dass die Glasfaser oder der Glasfaserausbau durch das Vectoring-Produkt der Telekom natürlich behindert wird. Dadurch wird eine alte Technologie, die, ja, ich sag mal, schon seit mehreren Jahren im Boden ist, die teilweise abgeschrieben ist, halt versucht, länger zu beleben und dann noch mehr höhere Bandbreiten zu bekommen. Aber letztendlich kann man über Kupfer ja heute natürlich auch 100 Megabit übertragen. Und es gibt andere Technologien, wo ich aber immer weiter dichter zum Kunden muss, auch mit meiner Glasfaser. Selbst die Telekom geht ja mit einer Glasfaser bis vor den KVZ, vor das Haus und macht den letzten Meter nur am Kupfer. Aber wenn man gleich mit Glasfaser zum Kunden gehen würde, hätte man natürlich die Bandbreiten direkt heute schon verfügbar.
Naja, aber sozusagen, das kann ja sein, das ist verschiedene Angebote. Aber was konkret hindert Wilhelm Tell daran, bei allen zu sein?
Ja, uns hindert ganz konkret, ich sag mal die Aussage, dass wir mit dem Breitbandausbau in Deutschland mit 50 Megabit uns zufriedenheben und nicht mit 100 Megabit oder Gigabit. Also es wird im Augenblick natürlich nichts gefördert, was wirklich rein glastechnisch ausgebaut ist. Und teilweise wird natürlich das, was in Glas ausgebaut wurde, durch die Telekom überbaut, beziehungsweise durch Vectoring, werden die Gebäude erschlossen und die Telekom hat dann ein Alleinversorgungsrecht in den Gebäuden.
Also das heißt sozusagen bei den Gebäuden, wo Glasfaser schon dran oder in der Nähe liegt, kommt man als andere anbieter, der nicht die Telekom ist, einfach nicht ran?
Genau.
Und jetzt fehlt gerade der Begriff Förderung. Das bedeutet, es würde sich nicht alleine lohnen, dass selber sozusagen alles zu bauen, sondern da bedürfte es staatlicher Förderung?
Na ja, zumindestens müsste man einfach dafür sorgen, ich sag mal von einer Regulierungsbehörde, dass Glasfaserausgebaute Gebiete dann auch Richtung Open Access geöffnet werden. Und mit dem Open Access dann auch die Telekom verpflichtet werden würde, auf diesem Netz, auf diesem Glasfasernetz seine Kunden zu versorgen. Damit würde man natürlich das Netz deutlich besser auslasten und die Effektivität und Wirtschaftlichkeit deutlich besser.
Das verstehe ich nicht ganz. Heißt das sozusagen, eine dritte Partei soll die Glasfasernetze bauen und dann soll jeder Anbieter darüber seinen Internetverkehr routen? Oder würde William Tell zum Beispiel selber auch was bauen und dann macht das jeder und dann haben wir irgendwann ganz Deutschland glasgefasert?
Also es wäre praktisch, also meiner Meinung nach ist es egal, ob ein Dritter das ausbaut und alle anderen nutzen das. Oder William Tell das ausbaut, nur dann nicht nochmal ein zweiter Parallel, eine Kochverbindung aufrüstet mit Vectoring oder nochmal überbaut, sondern dass man dann halt als zweiter mindestens diese vorhandenen Glasfasereinschlüsse benutzen kann.
Also überbauen heißt, nur um es mal noch kurz nachzufragen, das heißt einfach jemand anderes legt auch noch eine Leitung, irgendwo wo schon eine liegt?
Ja, also es ist ja so, selbst wenn wir jetzt ein Gebäude erschließen mit Glas, dann ist ja meistens schon Kupfer vorhanden durch die Telekom, weil ja fast jedes Gebäude erschlossen ist. Und wenn man jetzt Vectoring zusätzlich einbaut in den KVZs, um dann die alte Kupferleitung nochmal auf 100 Megabit fähig zu machen, obwohl es schon Glasfasereinschluss in dem Haus gibt, das macht für mich in meiner Meinung nach keinen Sinn. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Gibt es konkrete Forderungen, die Wilhelm Tell dann stellt, wo sie sagt, okay, da müsste vielleicht, keine Ahnung, eine Regulierungsbehörde oder die Politik im Allgemeinen oder irgendjemand irgendwas machen, damit das in Zukunft anders wird?
Ja, also der Glasfaserausbau sollte als Einziges gefördert werden. Damit würde auch die Telekom und andere Netzbetreiber verpflichtet werden, sozusagen dann in neueste Technologien bis zum Kunden zu investieren. Und das, ich sag mal, was heute in Glasfaser ausgebaut ist, kann man ja dann durch Open Access allen möglichen Mitbewerbern öffnen. Also wir machen das im Open Access-Bereich ja so, dass wir mehrere große Anbieter schon heute durchlassen. Also wir haben in Hamburg 25.000 Durchleitungskunden von einer Telefonika oder einer 1&1. Gerade Infrastruktur betreiben.
Halko Liebscher von Wilhelm Tell war das, ein kleiner Anbieter aus dem Norden Deutschlands und hat uns mal erklärt, woran es beim Glasfaserausbau so haken kann. Seine Forderungen sind zusammengefasst, es gibt tatsächlich sozusagen Fördergelder für den Breitbandausbau in Deutschland. Er sagt, die sollen nur noch für Glasfaser verwendet werden und die Glasfaser, die gebaut werden und wurden, sollten sozusagen geöffnet werden. Das heißt, da soll dann nicht nur ein Anbieter drauf dürfen und die benutzen dürfen, sondern mehrere. So, wenn in Deutschland irgendwas mit der Telekommunikation schief läuft, rufen alle immer, die Telekom ist schuld. Wie ist es wirklich, lieber Anwesende?
Stimmt doch auch.
Ich würde da mal gegensätzlich in meinem vertreten. Es ist nicht nur die Deutsche Telekom, die Schwierigkeit liegt darin, dass die Anreize fehlen. Und ich glaube, der Heiko Liebscher hat das auch ganz gut beschrieben. Wenn die Einreize da wären und die Kunden auch aufgeklärter wären, dann wäre das auch einfacher. Die Telekom ist nicht der einzige Access-Anbieter, den wir in Deutschland haben. Die großen drei, der zweite Telefoniker wurde eben auch schon genannt, das ist auch die Vodafone mit den Kabelfernsehnetzen, die sie jetzt dazu bekommen haben. Die alle drei gehen nicht diesen Weg, weil sie immer noch die Abschreibung haben wollen, weil es immer noch attraktiver ist, sich die Fördergelder für den DSL-Ausbau zu besorgen.
Bevor wir zu großen Föhn kommen, du hast gerade den Satz gesagt, die Kunden müssen aufgeklärt werden. Ich als Kunde bin aufgeklärt, in der Hinsicht, dass ich denke, ich möchte möglichst gern breitbandiges viel Internet her damit. Was meinst du mit Kunden aufklären?
Die Marketing-Abteilung der Unternehmen haben einen sehr guten Job darin getan, ein hochwertiges Produkt zu kreieren, was durch drei Buchstaben definiert ist, nämlich diese DSL, Digital Subscription Line. Wenn man das ins Deutsche übersetzt, ist das nichts weiter als eine digitale Übertragungsleitung. Das kann Glasfaser oder Kupfer sein. Aber die Leute assoziieren mit einem hochwertigen Internetanschluss immer ein DSL-Produkt. Damit auch damals mal ADSL, heute VDSL und AVDSL 2. Keiner kommt auf die Idee, so was wie GDSL oder so einzuführen, Glasfaser DSL, und ich glaube, dass es so auf diese einfache Formel zurückzuführen ist.
Ja, aber was ich mich frage, es gibt ja sozusagen einen wirtschaftlichen Raum, und diesem wirtschaftlichen Raum ist auch Platz für Anbieter, wie dem, was wir gerade gehört haben. Und ich frage mich schon, warum geht denn nicht einfach jemand hin und sagt, ich bau da jetzt in dieser Straße dieses Glasfaserding ein, und dann werden schon Kunden kommen. Also worauf wird denn da gewartet? Ich meine, man wartet anscheinend darauf, dass die Großen das irgendwie machen, aber...
Ja und nein. Also ich kann ein bisschen erzählen, wie das bei meinen Eltern passiert ist. Da haben die Stadtwerke gesagt, wir machen genau das. Die Stadtwerke, ich sag einfach mal, wo das ist, das ist in Marburg, die haben die letzten 10, 15 Jahre schon immer versucht, Internet zu den Leuten zu bringen. Die haben angefangen mit Richtfunksstrecken, die sie übers plattelande auf Funktürme gesetzt haben, und von da aus in die Dörfer gegangen sind, und da dann auch per WLAN und per Richtfunksstrecke in die einzelnen Privathaushalte Internet gebracht haben. Und die haben jetzt angefangen, dass sie gesagt haben, die Bandbreiten, die wir darüber kriegen, reichen nicht mehr. Wir machen das auch Glasfaser. Dann haben sie halt ein Jahr lang gebuddelt. Und ab dem Moment, ab dem sie gesagt haben, dass sie jetzt Glasfaser anbieten, da kamen dann auch zum Beispiel die Telekom und andere Anbieter und haben sehr günstige Angebote gemacht, die unter dem Preis waren, die das Glasfaser kosten würde. Und haben in den Prospekten behauptet, ja, das ist auch alles ganz schnell, weil wir bündeln jetzt euren langsam DSL-Anschluss mit LTE. Und wenn ich da jetzt als Kunde jetzt diesem Vollsprechen allen glaube und das kaufe, heißt das A, dass ganz viele Nachbarhäuser eben nicht diesen Glasfaseranschluss kaufen. Das heißt, für die Stadtwerke wird es dann teurer, das auszubauen, weil sie weniger Kunden haben, aber den gleichen Aufwand, die Straße aufzureißen erst mal. Und die Kunden haben das Gefühl, naja, ich kriege da billiger von der Telekom-Anschluss, der angeblich genauso schnell ist. Und ich brauche ja auch gar nicht so schnell das Internet. Ich mache da ja eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Und dann reicht das. Und hinterher stellt man fest, dass dann die LTE-Funktionelle halt überbucht ist, es alles langsam ist, vor allem abends. Und dann geht das alles nicht und Leute sind unglücklich. Das verhindert natürlich auch einen Ausbau, weil das sehen wir deutschlandweit, dass sobald kleinere Anbieter auf den Markt kommen und versuchen Glasfaser auszubauen, dann plötzlich die Großen kommen und sagen, jetzt müssen wir in diesem Markt hier in dieses Dorf wohl doch mal Glasfaser hinlegen und da irgendwie DSL ausbauen, weil sonst haben wir dieses Dorf verloren.
Und wenn einer der Großen sich jetzt entscheiden würde, zu sagen, wir machen den großen Umbau oder den großen Ausbau, der Erste ist derjenige, bei dem der Aktienkurs eindringt, weil sie das Geld jetzt erstmal für 20 Jahre in den Boden verseckt haben, bis es wieder reinkommt. Und es ist derjenige, der erstmal die Kosten hat. Das heißt, es ist das klassische Beamten-Mikado. Wer sich zuerst bewegt, hat den großen Nachteil.
Und mich der Dritte jetzt in der Runde. Man sollte auch mal ganz genau zuhören, was der Heiko gesagt hat. Der Heiko hat gesagt, dass er das, was er da gebaut hat, das Glasfaser nicht nur für seine eigenen Produkte gebaut hat, sondern er hat diese Glasfaser auch an andere vermietet und verkauft. Es ist wesentlich leichter, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Und wenn der Mieter in einem Haus zum Beispiel die freie Auswahl hat, welchen Provider er gerne hätte und der Provider, der da nicht selber ausgebaut hat, sich einfach die Faser, den Zugang dazu mietet. Das ist ein Volksmodell, was übrigens sehr gut auch im Ausland funktioniert. Man muss nicht immer alles selber in die Häuser bauen. Man kann das auch anmieten. Damit wird es auch leichter für kleinere Provider, einen, wie sagt man so schön, Business Case daraus zu machen und damit auch Geld zu verdienen.
Ja, aber jetzt bin ich wieder verwirrt, weil was du gesagt hast, Stefan, lässt mich noch mal die Frage stellen, warum passiert das dann nicht? Also es passiert sozusagen lokal eingeschränkt, aber das ist doch ein ganz hervorragendes Modell. Ich gehe hierhin als kleiner Anbietersager so hier, ich leg dir Glasfaser ins Haus, ich vermiete das an die großen Anbieter. Also worauf genau warten die Leute? Und ich find auch komisch, dass du das Filz gesagt hast, wer es zuerst bewegt, fällt um, weil es ist doch absehbar, dass wir so viel Internet brauchen oder nicht.
Aber ich kann doch noch Geld machen, ohne das Geld zu investieren. Warum sollte ich es also tun?
Na weil du dann der Erste bist und sagen, die Kunden dann zu dir kommen. Weil du dann entweder sozusagen ganz viele neue Kunden hast oder diese Glasfaser, die du gelegt hast, an andere Anbieter verwenden kannst.
Aber es ist doch egal, solange niemand ausbaut, verliert dir auch niemand.
Irgendwann crash das halt, aber dann haben wir alle verloren. Dann sind wir aber wieder bei den kleinen Anbietern, die sagen, naja, wenn die großen das nicht machen, dann machen wir das halt.
Das Problem ist, dass so ein kleiner Anbieter es nicht flächendeckend anbieten kann. Das heißt, wenn ein kleiner Anbieter das in seinem Bereich macht, kommt halt sofort ein großer Anbieter und unterbietet ihn und nimmt ihm im Prinzip die Kunden weg, was ich eben von Stadtwerken erzählt habe.
Aber dafür haben wir doch eine Regulierungsbehörde, oder nicht?
Aber der Markt ist doch nicht reguliert. Reguliert wird der Markt in dem Moment, in dem es einen großen gibt, der den Markt so sehr beherrscht, dass er reguliert werden muss.
Also es gibt doch die Bundesnetzagentur.
Ja, die gerade erlaubt hat, dass die Telekom allein Vectoring machen darf auf ihren KVZ.
So, dann erklärt mir mal, wie das jetzt sozusagen, also es gibt doch wahrscheinlich einen Plan, wie das doch noch klappen kann. Also ich fasse mal zusammen, was ich von euch mitbekommen habe. Die kleinen Anbieter machen es nicht, weil sie dann von den Großen ausgebotet werden. Die großen Anbieter machen es nicht, weil sie noch sehr lange Geld verdienen können. Damit ist nicht zu machen. Und die Bundesnetzagentur, die eigentlich die Stelle wäre, die sagen könnte, so Leute, ihr verhindert aktiv eine Technologie, die wir dringend brauchen. Ihr macht jetzt das jetzt mal oder wir fördern die kleinen. Die sozusagen hält die Füße still und sagt so, Vectoring, diese völlig veraltete Technologie, wo die Kupferkabel im Haus weiter benutzt werden, die ist total super.
Na ja, was du machen kannst, ist selber aktiv werden. Also als das im Dorf von meinen Eltern anfing, habe ich halt meinen Eltern erklärt, warum sie Glasfaser haben möchten, warum sie nicht dieses Alternativprodukt haben möchten, und dass sie bitte allen ihren Nachbarn das auch erklären sollen. Und ich glaube zwei Drittel oder 70 Prozent der gesamten Häuser in diesem Ort haben jetzt Glasfaser und werden demnächst nicht mehr bei der Telekom-Kunden sein. Also wenn die zwei Jahre Vertragslaufzeit abgelaufen sind, wo die Leute noch alle drinstecken. Das heißt, du musst halt selber Leute aktiv überzeugen und erklären, dass sie auch wenn es jetzt erstmal mehr kostet, sie vielleicht Glasfaser wirklich kaufen wollen, auch mit den Nachbarn zusammen das machen wollen, um dann auf lange Sicht auch was davon zu haben. Weil letztlich werden diese Häuser in dem Ort, die Glasfaser haben, später auch für teures Geld verkauft werden. Weil nachträglich kommt das nicht mehr.
Das kann ich machen, wenn ich auch Eltern habe, die in einem Dorf leben, was ich nicht habe. Aber ich mein, um habe ich das falsch im Kopf, ist in der Politik doch in der ganzen Zeit von Breitbandausbau geredet, oder nicht? Wollen wir Deutschland irgendwie zu Breitbandland werden und so was? Gibt es nicht irgendwie so bunte Broschüren?
Ja, haben wir sogar eine gerade hier. Was ist das Ziel bis 2030? 50 Megabit oder so. Und das ist halt genau zufälligerweise das, was diesem Vectoring geht. Also Hauptsache keine neue Technik.
Das ist doch unfassbar. Fils, du bist doch jetzt, wie heißt der Verein, wo du bist? Oder der Anbieter?
Ich bin bei In Berlin.
In Berlin. Und ihr baut sowas selber?
Wir haben damals angefangen, wie ESDN Einwahl und Modemeinwahl für die Leute anzubieten. Aber im Prinzip mit dem DSL-Markt ist es fast nicht mehr möglich, zu den Leuten nach Hause irgendwelche Technik zu legen. ESDN, sie sind halt wirklich in Reichweite, dass man ein bisschen Richtfunk machen kann. Weil die Zugangskosten, wenn man jetzt Leitungen von der Telekom anmieten muss, wir haben in Berlin 40 Hauptverteiler. 140 Hauptverteiler. In jedem müsste man eine Leitung legen. In jedem müsste man sich von der Telekom Fläche anmieten. Das Geld kann man als kleiner überhaupt nicht aufbringen.
Das heißt zu sagen, das ist momentan nur noch ein Verein, der für die alten Zeiten da ist, aber...
Nein, wir bieten Hosting an, wir bieten es den Leuten an, dass sie ihren eigenen Server bei uns unterstellen können.
Ich wollte sagen, fürs Internet nach Hause bringen.
Aber fürs Internet nach Hause bieten können wir den Leuten nur sagen, ihr könnt VPN mit einer festen IP-Adresse bekommen und dann im Prinzip durch einen Tunnel, durch euren DSL-Anschluss, direkt durchtunneln.
Genau, da brauch ich ja schon mal Internet. Ich muss noch kurz fragen, du hast am Anfang gesagt, du hast dein eigenes Internet gemacht.
Ich habe ursprünglich dafür gesorgt, dass wir die Einwahltechnik haben, dass wir in der Lage sind, wir haben dafür gesorgt, dass wir in der Lage sind, uns halt über das Telefonnetz, was damals die einzige Möglichkeit war, Internet nach Hause zu bekommen. Das war der ursprüngliche Zweck.
Mit eigener IP-Adresse, mit Diensten, die man anbieten kann und so weiter und so fort.
Ohne dass einem einer in die Suppe spuckt und vielleicht irgendwelche Dienste, die man gerne hat, runtershaped oder filtert.
Okay, aber sagen, ihr könnt auch keinen Glasfaser herzaubern?
Nein.
Schade.
Das Grundproblem mit dem Glasfaser ist, der Business Case wurde angesprochen, die Verlegekosten innerhalb der Stadt sind extrem hoch. Denn die Glasfaser wird heute noch auch zu den Häusern in einer Qualität verlegt, die für Rechenzentren geeignet ist. Also mit einer fast hundertprozentigen Verfügbarkeit. Jeder DSL-Anschluss und jeder, der sich mal seine allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen durchgelesen hat, hat eine schlechtere. Meist unter 90 Prozent sogar. Das heißt, wenn man die Glasfaserkabel mit demselben Verfügbarkeit verlegen würde, Schlitzverlegung, nur 10, 20 Zentimeter unter dem Gehsteig, eine Plattenreihe aufnehmen, würde man, und ich bin jetzt kein Tiefbauingenieur, aber ich würde mal aus dem Bau heraus sagen, ein zwanzigstel Kosten pro laufendem Meter haben. Und damit wird es auch einfacher, auch für so ein Innenberlin vielleicht mal eine Straße mit Glas zu versorgen. Aber solange das nicht möglich ist oder wo der Hemmschuh liegt, ob das die Bezirksämter, die Bauämter sind, wer da blockiert, das müsste man mal genauer evaluieren. Aber es scheint da ein Problem zu geben.
Okay, gut. Wir sprechen noch gleich genauer über das Problem, machen vorher noch eine kurze Pause, gibt noch einmal Musik von King White-Nay, dann gibt es die Nachrichten und dann sozusagen, ich möchte in einer halben Stunde noch wissen, wie ich, wenn wir uns nächstes Jahr an dieser Stelle wieder treffen, mindestens ein Gigabit zu Hause bei mir zu liegen habe.
Das erste Lollapaloozer hier in der Gegend fandet ihr...
Mega.
Das zweite Lollapaloozer war eher so...
Der Wahnsinn, wirklich. Mega, hammergeil.
Geile Party. Und das dritte Lollapaloozer wird... All das plus Hui mal zwei hoch Fritz.
Fritz präsentiert...
Das Lollapaloozer Festival. Mit dabei... Mumford & Sons... Crow und die Foo Fighters. Und The X-Ex. Marshmallow... Und Materia. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Diesmal auf der Rennbahn Hoppergarten. Wer da noch alles auftritt und wo man Karten kaufen oder sogar gewinnen kann, fritz.de slash lala.
Der absolute Ebershit präsentiert von Fritz.
Fritz Nachrichten mit Martin Schneider.
Die britische Regierung hat ihre Pläne für den Weg zum Brexit vorgestellt. Der zuständige Minister Davies kündigte in London ein Gesetz an, mit dem zunächst die Geltung von EU-Recht in Großbritannien aufgehoben werden soll. Damit es durch den Austritt nicht zum Chaos kommt, sollen gleichzeitig mehr als 10.000 EU-Vorschriften in nationales Recht übertragen werden. Nach und nach sollen sie geprüft und gegebenenfalls geändert werden. Streit dürfte es über die Pläne der konservativen Regierung geben, einzelne Vorschriften ohne Zustimmung des Parlaments zu ändern. Der Bundestag hat dem Gesetzentwurf für mehr Lohngleichheit zwischen Frauen und Männer beschlossen. Nach der neuen Regelung müssen Arbeitnehmer in Betrieben mit mehr als 200 Beschäftigten über die Bezahlung von Kollegen mit vergleichbaren Aufgaben informiert werden. Der Bundestag hat außerdem einem Gesetzentwurf zum automatisierten Fahren auf deutschen Straßen zugestimmt. Künftig dürfen damit Computer in Autos die Steuerung übernehmen. Der Fahrer muss aber jederzeit eingreifen können. Hunderte Menschen in Südbrandenburg müssen nicht für den Braunkohletagebau umziehen. Die Pläne zum Ausbau des Tagebaus in der Lausitz werden deutlich gekürzt. Das gab der Energiekonzern LEAG am Abend bekannt. Demnach wird der Tagebau Jens Schwalde nicht weitergeführt, weil das dazugehörige 40 Jahre alte Kraftwerk technisch nicht mehr zeitgemäß sei. Ob jedoch der Tagebau Weltsow Süd noch erweitert wird, will die LEAG bis 2020 entscheiden. Die Deutschen essen immer weniger Fleisch. Letztes Jahr lag der Fleischkonsum pro Kopf im Schnitt bei 60 Kilo. Das hat die Bundesanstalt für Landwirtschaft und Ernährung ausgerechnet. Vor 20 Jahren hat jeder Deutsche statistisch noch 8 Kilo mehr gegessen. Am beliebtesten ist Schweinefleisch. Das machte letztes Jahr einen Anteil von 60 Prozent aus. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn 13 Grad, in Wilmersdorf 15, Frankfurt-Oder und Ludwigsfelde 13 Grad, Joachimsthal 14 und Pritzwerg sogar noch 16 Grad. Bis zum Morgen werden die Wolken weniger, es bleibt trocken bei minimal 10 bis 6 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann viel Sonne und bis zu 25 Grad. Es gibt ein paar Vollsperrungen, alle bis morgen früh um 5, nämlich auf der A100 Stadtring Richtung Knoikölln zwischen dem Jakob-Kaiserplatz und Hohenzollern-Damm, auf der A111 Stadt Autobahn Richtung Dreik-Charlotten-Bürg zwischen Hecker-Damm und Dreik-Charlotten-Bürg und auch auf der A115-Avus statt einwärts ist im Dreik-Funktum die Überleitung zur A100 Richtung Wilmersdorf gesperrt. Ansonsten Rollz, daraus geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Pritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Ihr hört das Chaos-Radio im Blue Moon und dort gibt es natürlich immer die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo, vorgetragen von Martin Schneider.
Bundestag fordert vertrauenswürdige Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung. Die Große Koalition fordert sichere elektronische Kommunikation und vertrauenswürdige Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung. In einem Antrag zum innovativen Staat wird verlangt, sichere und vertrauenswürdige Verschlüsselungsverfahren sowie deren Implementierung und einfache Handhabbarkeit zu fördern und zu unterstützen. Für den Antrag stimmten die Fraktionen der SPD und CDU und CSU. Die Grünen enthielten sich, die Linke stimmte gegen den Antrag. Hackerangriff auf den Bundestag. Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik berichtet über einen erneuten Cyberangriff auf den Bundestag, der aber abgewehrt wurde. Nach der Analyse des BSI scheint es sich dabei, um einen Malvatizing-Angriff auf einer Nachrichtenseite gehandelt zu haben, die keinen signifikanten Einfluss auf die überwachten Netze gehabt hat. Das BSI hat keine Schadsoftware entdeckt, auch Infektionen sind nicht bekannt.
Das war die NerdNews von Matten Schneider, vielen Dank! Eine halbe Stunde noch im Chaosradio im Blue Moon und willkommen zurück. Montags, nabend, Stefan, hallo und Johannes. Wir wollen noch eine halbe Stunde darüber reden, warum wir noch kein breitbandiges Internet per Glasfaser zu Hause haben. Ich möchte kurz einen kleinen Schwenker machen. Habt ihr es in den NerdNews gerade gehört? Also die Regierung fordert Verschlüsselung und CDU und SPD stimmen dafür und der Rest dagegen? Oder enthalten sich? Was ist da los? Das ist eine völlig verkehrte Welt.
Ich habe keinen Blassen.
Das müssen wir nochmal genauer. Also das würde mich ja nochmal genau interessieren. Aber es ist vielleicht auch eine andere Sendung. So, wir kommen zurück zum Glasfaser. Wir haben schon gerade drüber gesprochen, also schon sehr lange drüber gesprochen, dass wir im Prinzip Glasfaser wollen, weil schönes, schnelles Internet, aber das nicht geht, weil über Kupfer liegt. Und weder die Kleinen noch die großen Anbieter machen das. Und reguliert wird das auch nicht. Und wir haben noch einen Anrufer, den wir kurz reinnehmen wollen, den Frank. Der hat nämlich eine wilde Theorie, warum die Telekom vielleicht nicht Glasfaser ausbaut.
Hallo, also erst mal möchte ich sagen, also ich habe nichts gegen Glasfaser, nicht falsch verstehen. Ich bin trotzdem Telekom-Kunde, ich habe alle bei der Telekom. Ich habe auch IPTV über die Telekom. Also deshalb kann ich auch nicht zu irgendeinem anderen Anbieter wechseln. Und mich ärgert, wenn man so die News immer hört. Also ich hoffe und setze eigentlich auf VDSL2, dass ich das endlich mal bekomme. Aber dadurch, dass irgendwelche Kamminetzanbieter ständig irgendwelche Einsprüche einlegen, vor irgendwelche Gerichte ziehen, verzögert sich das alles. Und das finde ich genauso zum kotzen, als wenn man jetzt dieses Telekom-Monopol kritisiert. Das ist natürlich auch nicht in Ordnung. Da würde ich gerne mal eure Meinung hören.
Also, weil ich es richtig verstanden habe, soll VDSL2, was genau ist das?
VDSL2, der Nachfolger mit 100 MBit, jetzt im Augenblick noch im Downlink, also zum Kunden hin und 50 MBit vom Kunden, also 40 MBit in Richtung des Internets. VDSL2 wird, weil es sehr viel näher dieser dieser Schrank auf der Straße sehr viel näher an der Wohnung dranstehen muss, weil das Kabel wieder ein bisschen kürzer sein muss, um diese Bandbreite zu garantieren, wird das nicht bei allen gleich ausgebaut. Das zweite Problem ist, dass man Änderungen an den Schränken in der Straße durchführen muss und die es wird halt, da gibt es Ausbaupläne. Ich vermute im Internet gibt es eine Seite, da steht dann irgendwann drin, wann man es bekommen kann.
Aber was hat ihr jetzt von der Theorie sozusagen, dass der Ausbau mit breitbehaltener Internet dadurch sozusagen verhindert wird, dass die Telekom verklagt wird? Das habe ich nicht ganz genau verstanden. Also, weil das...
Na was verhindert wird, ist, dass die Telekom in den Kabelverzweigern, die da an der Straße stehen, die Technik so umbaut, dass die anderen ausgesperrt werden. Das ist das, was die Telekom im Prinzip da gerade aktiv tut. Mit mehr oder weniger technischen Gründen. Das hatten wir vorhin ja kurz gesagt. Wenn ich verschiedene Anbiete da drin habe, müssten die sich so synchronisieren, dass die Leitungen sich nicht gegenseitig stören, weil die Frequenzen die da übertragen werden, so hoch sind, dass das sonst sehr schnell passiert.
Also warte, ich will gucken, ob ich es verstanden habe. Die Telekom würde in die Kästen eine neue Technologie einbauen, um das Kupferinternet doch noch ein bisschen breitbandiger zu machen. Das würde dann aber dazu führen, dass sie sagen, ja, aber dann können wir keinen anderen mehr reinlassen, weil dann würden sie wieder stören.
Naja, nicht auf demselben Weg wieder rein. Sie dürfen sie ja nicht ganz aussperren, deswegen würden sie sie nicht ganz aussperren, sondern würden nur sagen, ihr dürft jetzt nicht euren eigenen Schrank daneben stellen, sondern ihr müsst jetzt von uns den Zugang zu gewissen Preisen einkaufen. Die sind halt deutlich höher als das, was die Mitbewerber jetzt zahlen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip bekommt dann andere Anbieter nur noch einen Tunnel über die Technik von der Telekom und hat auch selber keinen Einfluss mehr auf irgendwelche technischen Parameter, die da laufen.
Also quasi, die Abwägung, die gemacht wird, ist, entweder man lässt die Telekom gewähren, dann hätte man sozusagen einen Monopol, aber breitbändiges Internet oder man nimmt in Kauf, dass das verhindert wird, damit alle die Chance haben, da was zu machen.
Genau, dann müssen wir eben mal auf eine neue innovative Technik wieder das Glas setzen.
Okay, dann will ich den Frank kurz fragen, ob das deine Frage beantwortet.
Ja, dann hab ich noch kurz eine Frage. Also, was ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist, es werden doch bei den Telekom Kästen nur die DSL und VDSL-Anschlüsse denn monopolisiert. Glasfaser kann noch weiter, da braucht es doch nicht ein extra Kasten, die müssen einfach nur eine extra Leitung legen.
Ja, okay, also Frank, da würde ich aber tatsächlich bitten, lad dir nach der Sendung bitte den Podcast runter, weil genau dieses Thema, also was ist das Komplizierte am Glasfaseraufbau, das haben wir schon ganz ausführlich gesprochen.
In einem Satz das buddeln, das buddeln.
So sieht's aus. Und ich würde jetzt gerne sagen, zurückkommen zur, wie soll man sagen, zur Politik. Also gibt es vielleicht, also wir haben schon gehört, die Politik fordert irgendwie 100 MBit für alle oder in die 50 sogar nur. Also was sozusagen das ist, was wir eh schon haben. Gibt es vielleicht trotzdem irgendwo Pläne oder Visionen, dass wir irgendwie noch Glasfaser haben könnten?
Ja, man kann so ein bisschen in Berlin zumindest, kann man in den Koalitionsvertrag gucken und da feststellen, dass da verabredet ist, dass Glasfaser ausgebaut werden soll. Es wird aber nicht gesagt, wie, weil das ist aber natürlich logisch, weil in so einem Vertrag steht jetzt auch nicht jedes Detail drin. Sondern man will jetzt prüfen, wie man das in Berlin möglichst voranbringen könnte und möglicherweise mit landeseigenen Gesellschaften zusammenarbeiten könnte. Weil es gibt ja, Wasserbetriebe haben wir eben schon mal gehört, gibt ja Gesellschaften, die haben schon Infrastrukturen, die man vielleicht nutzen könnte, um weitere Kabel zu verlegen.
Ist es wirklich so das, was sich jetzt sozusagen dem Hirn anbietet? Nämlich die Wassergewerke haben einen Wasserrohr. Das heißt, ich hänge in das Wasserrohr einen Kabel rein?
So ungefähr war das ja bei der Berlikom, die ja ein Offspin sozusagen von einem Wasserbetrieb gewesen ist. Der Stefan weiß das alles im Detail noch ein bisschen genauer. Aber es war im Kern so, dass eine vorhandene Infrastruktur eben Abwasserkanäle und solches genutzt hat, um da drin einfach ohne zu buddeln, Kabel zu verlegen.
Aber das steht jetzt in einem Koalitionsantrag drin. Ich weiß, dass Sie jetzt ein bisschen Glaskugel lesen, aber hast du den Eindruck, das ist so was, da schreibt man da rein, weil es klingt gut und man muss sich auch nicht festlegen? Oder kann man da wirklich damit rechnen, dass so eine Art politischer Innovationsdruck entsteht?
Also ich glaube, einen Druck weiß ich nicht, aber es wird schon Initiativen geben. Es hat ja in der letzten Berliner Legislaturperiode ja auch schon so ein paar Initiativen gegeben mit diesem B-Digital und den Arbeitskreis Digitalisierung, den der Regine Bürgermeister initiiert hat, der aber seit dem Ende 2015 auch so ein bisschen schläft, glaube ich. Aber dadurch, dass das eben im Vertrag drin steht und speziell bei den Linken und bei den Grünen in den Wahlprogrammen schon drin stand, muss man jetzt mal gucken, wie in den Haushaltsberatungen, die jetzt anfangen für den Doppelhaushalt 2018, 2019, wie das da implementiert wird, dass hier so was geprüft werden soll. Also im Grunde genommen, so kleine Schritte. Das ist aber genau der Moment, wo wir haben ja am Anfang schon mal von Einmischen gesprochen, wo man sich theoretisch auch einmischen kann über Abgeordnete und andere Kanäle, um sich da einzubringen in so einen Diskussionsprozess, der gerade beginnt.
Okay. Wie ist es denn, wir haben Berlin vielleicht, Hamburg haben wir gehört, es gibt so ein paar Dinge. Es hat ein Hörer uns auch geschrieben, dass an der niederländischen Grenze anscheinend auch sozusagen eine Firma dabei ist, Dörfer einzusammeln und zu verglasfasern. Wie ist denn das eigentlich so, und der hat ja erklärt, woran das liegt, dass es nicht passiert. Das hängt vor allem mit Geldverdienen zusammen und dass es noch gut ohne Glasfaser geht. Wie ist denn das so im internationalen Vergleich? Sind wir da Breitbandvorreiter oder liegt in den anderen Ländern schon die Glasfaser?
Wenn du die Liste umdrehst, dann ja. Ich meine, stehen wir dieses Jahr auf der OECD-Liste überhaupt drauf.
Wie lange ist sie?
Ne, vorletzte glaube ich nach Litauen.
Wie lang ist sie?
Genau, es stehen 20 Länder auf dieser Liste drauf. Und wir sind auf Platz 18? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Verstehe. 26, Entschuldigung. Aber gibt es schon Länder, wo Glasfaser im Privatbereich sich wirklich durchgesetzt hat?
Sehr viele. Also Südkorea ganz massiv. In der Schweiz ist es sehr einfach. Bitte mal jetzt da noch rezitieren. Wir haben die Liste ja hier gerade vor uns. Also im Prinzip alle europäischen Länder sind da vor uns. Moment mal.
Also mal die Frau Cyprus zu zitieren, die ein Werbeflyer heute in die Zeit reingepackt hat. Global, innovativ und fair. Wir machen Zukunft digital. Da gibt es auf der Seite 4 eine Statistik. Platz 1 bis 26. 26 Deutschland mit 13, 7 Mbit. Durchschnittlicher Geschwindigkeit. Südkorea mit 26, 3. Hongkong, Norwegen, Schweden, Schweiz, Singapur, Japan, Finnland, Niederlande, Lettland. Das waren nur die ersten 10. Danach hat man sich dann gespart, die restlichen 15, die noch vor uns liegen, noch aufzuzählen.
Durchschnittliche Bandbreite.
Aber weiß man denn, wie die das gemacht haben? Warum zur Hölle noch mal liegt dort Glasfaser? Wie haben die das geschafft? Dieses Konglomerat aus großen Telekom-Firmen und fauler Politik. Ich meine, wir sind ja da nicht einzigartig in Deutschland.
Also in Südkorea zum Beispiel gab es eine große Initiative eines landesweiten Glasfaserausbaus, wo im Prinzip staatlich ein Großteil des Landes mit Glasfaser versorgt wurde.
Aber hat der Staat das selber gebaut? Oder der Staat hat die Firmen dazu verdonnert? Oder hat er gefördert? Also wie genau ist das passiert?
Man kann vermuten, dass das in Südkorea, das ist ein sehr spezieller Fall, weil man in Südkorea ja so ein paar ganz große Unternehmen hat, die fast staatsgleich schon sind, so Samsung und andere. Und da gibt es immer ein sehr enges Hand in Hand zwischen Regierung und Wirtschaft. Und insofern, wenn die das gemeinsam beschließen, wenn wir nötig befinden und das primär dann sicherlich erstmal auf den Großraum Soul sich fokussieren. Wenn man da mal gewesen ist, dann sieht man, wie da aber auch die Kabel verlegt werden. Das wird ein bisschen lockerer gehandhabt, auch bei uns. Oder auch in China. Dann kann man aber auch verstehen, warum das da viel viel schneller geht. Und die eine Penetration haben von 70 Prozent der Haushalte, die mit Glasfaser erreicht werden. Bei uns sind es 1, 2 oder irgendwas. Unabhängig von den Bandbreiten noch mal.
Nun darf man auch nicht vergessen, wenn wir uns zum Beispiel jetzt mal mit den USA vergleichen, dass der Vergleich hinkt noch mehr. Die stehen auch nicht viel besser da als wir. Aber dort ist es auch um Größenordnungen billiger, Haushalte anzuschließen, weil man es dort einfach an die Strommasten knüppert.
Aber um nochmal deine Frage aufzugreifen. Wir können ja mal ein Land nehmen, was nicht in Europa liegt. Und ich spiele jetzt nicht auf die Briten an, sondern auf die Schweiz. Die Schweiz hat es geschafft, die lokalen Platzführer, die Swisscom, dazu zu verdonnern in den großen Städten, den Glasfaserausbau voranzutreiben und anderen Providern den Zugang zu geben. Und das funktioniert dann so, dass die das Kabel halt in die Wohnung reinlegen. Und da gibt es einen Verteiler, so ein großes Metallgestell. Da kommen die ganzen Kabel, die ganzen Buchsen an, die zu den Wohnungen führen. Und man kann sich halt diese Glasfaser mieten und das zu einem fairen Preis, was dazu geführt hat, dass es auch jetzt Provider gibt, die sehr attraktive Gigabit-Angebote für Privatkunden anbieten, was wiederum natürlich auch den Platzführer dazu zwingt, neue Produkte anzubieten. Man nennt so was auch freien Wettbewerb.
Naja, aber trotzdem, wenn der eine Punkt sagt, die müssen das verlegen und dann wird ihnen vorgeschrieben, wie viel sie nehmen dürfen, oder haben die nur gesagt, also macht mal, aber wir gucken schon drauf, was sie da tut?
Die müssen die Faser Dritten zur Verfügung stellen. Das nennt man diskriminierungsfreien Zugriff.
Ja, aber dann können die ja immer noch die Preise festlegen. Also wie ist geregelt, dass die dann nicht sagen, hey, ihr könnt natürlich sozusagen 1000 Euro fürs... und so weiter.
Da das wahrscheinlich eine ganz stark politische Frage ist, kann man da natürlich, wenn man politisch aktiv ist, Einfluss draufnehmen. Und das scheint in der Schweiz geklappt zu haben. Und der Preis scheint so gut zu sein, dass es sich lohnt, in der Schweiz Glasfaseranschlüsse für Endkunden anzubieten.
Ja, was ist deine Lösung, sag mal?
Ja, endlich alle ideologischen Schranken über Wortwärts und eine komplette Verstaatlichung der Infrastruktur fordern. Also weg von dieser Kleinstatter reich.
Das ist doch Kommunismus! Nein, aber mal ehrlich, ich mein, mal abgesehen davon, dass Deutschland sozusagen sehr viel privatisiert hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten, ist das eine Idee, die auch sozusagen, also wo man sagt, okay, lieber Staat, deine Aufgabe ist, das Infrastruktur bereitzustellen?
Das machen wir doch, das heißt halt dann Telekom und die gehört dem Staat.
Ihr habt mir gerade fast zwei Stunden lang erklärt, dass die Telekom keine Glasfaser baut. So, jetzt nochmal die Frage, gibt es das als Idee oder politische Forderung irgendwie, dass man dem Staat dazu verdonnert, sozusagen, du musst das selber bauen?
Nein. Also nichts, das mir da bekannt ist, es mag vielleicht jetzt in bestimmten Landesparlamenten Ideen geben, aber auf Bundesebene habe ich davon noch gar nichts gehört.
Was würdet ihr davon halten?
Wäre das eine gute Idee? Es gibt diesen schönen Spruch, der Strom kommt aus der Steckdose und dann kommt das Internet auch aus der Steckdose. Und wir haben nachgewiesen, wir hatten Amerika gerade genannt mit dem maroden Stromnetz, wir haben nachgewiesen, dass eine Teilverstaatlichung von Infrastruktur keine so schlechte Idee ist. Und es gibt auch diese Ideen, dass man sagt, man trennt, wie bei der Deutschen Bahn, zum Beispiel das Streckennetz von dem, der nachher die Züge darauf rollen lässt. Und genau so ein Modell könnte in der Telekommunikation funktionieren. Aber da würde ich sagen, es gibt da immer noch unvor 20 Milliarden Euro, die die Telekom wert ist, Anteile von einer Telekom, die noch vom Staat gehalten wird über die KfW. Wenn man das so was verkaufen würde, das ist jetzt keine Idee, die ich hatte, das kann man nachlesen bei Heise, dann würde man dieses Geld natürlich wunderbar für so ein Initial, für so ein Start nutzen können, um so was zu realisieren. Ein Netz, was diskriminierungsfrei von allen Providern genutzt werden kann.
Vor allem das Schöne ist ja, dass man bei diesem Netz gar nicht alles auf einmal machen muss. Wir haben sehr, sehr viele Kommunen und sehr viele Stadtwerke, die lokal genau das versuchen. Also wie gesagt, das Beispiel von meinen Eltern zu Hause, die haben sechs Fasern in jede Wohneinheit und da können auch andere Anbieter sich diese Dark Fiber in die Wohnung kaufen und können dann da eigene Dienste drüber anbieten, unabhängig von diesen Stadtwerken, weil die erst mal nur die Infrastruktur hingelegt haben. Und man bekommt auch die Infrastruktur von denen, ohne bei denen einen Vertrag abzuschließen, dann bekommt man zwar keine Förderung, hat aber die Infrastruktur trotzdem da zum vernünftigen Preis.
Darf ich mal reingrätschen? Ja, da sind wir aber wieder bei enorm unnötigen Kosten und enorm verlangsamten Ausbau. Erklär mir mal, warum wir in Deutschland drei oder vier Handynetze brauchen. Wir haben drei oder vier miserable Handynetze. Das ist doch die Kermotte. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Spektrum, auch in der Luft, das ist ja das gleiche Thema wie zu Hause. Ich habe genau jedes Megahertz festgelegt. Ich kann nicht ausbrechen.
Aber Joseph, ich würde es gerne ein bisschen abkürzen. Seine Forderung ist generell kritische Infrastrukturen sollte man sozusagen verstehen.
In Frankreich, zum Beispiel mit der Kanalisation, war es genauso. Da hat man es privatisiert. Die Privaten haben ihr Geld rausgezogen, vergammeln lassen. In der Stadt muss es zurückkaufen, damit es zu keiner Umweltkatastrophe kommt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht zu sagen, ob Glasfaser auch vergammelt ist. Das dauert 100 Jahre. Also, Joseph, ich würde es an dieser Stelle kurz abbrechen wollen, weil ich möchte euch noch eine andere Frage stellen. Wenn in den Nachrichten von Breitbandausbau die Rede ist, dann wird die Industrie immer zitiert mit, ja, da muss der Staat fördern.
Er muss halt richtig fördern. Wenn ich einem großen Anbieter das Geld gebe für einen Breitbandausbau, der auf alte Technologie setzt, nämlich auf das Kupfer, dann bekomme ich halt keine Innovationen raus. Wenn ich jetzt das Geld nehme und Kommunen gebe, dann habe ich da sicherlich ein ganz anderes Ergebnis. Wenn die Kommunen nämlich dann anfangen können, ihre Industriegebiete und ihre Gewerbegebiete mit schnellem Internet zu versorgen, dann wandern da nämlich auch nicht die Firmen ab. Wenn ich ein Architekturbüro habe, das in einem Neubaugebiet sitzt, wo der Inhaber des Architekturbüros jeden Tag mit einem USB-Stick ins Internetcafé in die Stadt fahren muss, um seine Skizzen loszuwerden, das ist Realität.
Ja, aber warte, es gibt Fördertöpfe und die sollen sozusagen den Kommunen gegeben werden. Und die sollen die dann frei entscheiden können. Also quasi entweder wir verlegen die Kabel selber oder wir beauftragen jemanden, der das macht. Also meinetwegen auch einen großen Telekom-Anbieter kann man ja sagen. Kann hingehen und sagen, pass auf Telekom-Anbieter, die Frage ist nicht, ob wir das machen oder nicht, sondern die Frage ist, willst du das machen oder nicht?
Na, wenn dafür gesorgt ist, dass mit diesem öffentlichen Geld danach ein diskriminierungsfreies Netz da ist, was eben nicht wieder das Monopolselementiert, weil dazu hohe Preise von den Mitbewerbern verlangt werden.
Ich wäre absolut im Augenblick dagegen, irgendwelche Fördergelder rauszugeben. Ich würde die gesamte Förderung einstellen. Warum? Der Hintergrund dabei ist, dass einfach zu wenig kontrolliert wird, was rauskommt. Es wird zu wenig zweckgebunden gefördert. Man fördert den Ausbau des Breitbandes in Bayern. Jetzt versucht man in München als kleine Firma einen Glasfaseranschluss zu kriegen. Man ist ein innovatives Start-up-Unternehmen, man kriegt es nicht. Aber wie der Bitkom-Präsident gerade gesagt hat, die deutschen Bauernhöfe haben mehr digitale Technik im Einsatz als der Mittelstand in Deutschland. Woran liegt das?
Die müssen aber auch ihre Traktoren hacken, habe ich neulich gelesen.
Sie haben aber auch Drohnen im Einsatz und jede Kuh hat einen Chip im Ohr. Es ist einfach so, dass es dann ganz große Schere gibt. Solange Gelder einfach mit der Gießkanne vergeben, ausgestreut werden, und so ist der Eindruck, der bei mir einfach hängen bleibt, wenn ich die Werbepamplete zum Thema Breitbandausbau lese und das nicht zweckgebunden ist und auch nicht mal berücksichtigt wird, dass die Demoskopie sagt, dass über 90 Prozent der deutschen Bevölkerung in großstädtischen Ballungsräumen lebt und dafür anscheinend kein Konzept ist, außer dass man da vorgaukelt, dass es dort einen freien Wettbewerb gibt, dann sollen sie einen freien Wettbewerb schaffen und dann sollten sie vielleicht das eine Unternehmen, was teilweise in staatlicher Hand ist, vielleicht überlegen, was sie damit machen, versilbern und das Geld für Für sinnvolle Zwecke einsetzen, zweckgebunden.
Vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung dazu. Fördern heißt auch nicht notwendigerweise, dass Geld vergeben wird, weil beispielsweise die Telekom keine Fördergelder in der Regel braucht, aber natürlich Investitionen nur dann tätigt, wenn sie einen gewissen Bestandsschutz auch bekommt, über lockere Regulierungsvorgaben. Also das ist ja ein ganz wesentlicher Teil. Gerade bei diesem Vectoring war das ja ein ganz wesentlicher Diskussionspunkt. Immer ein wichtiges Argument der Telekom, die gesagt hat, wir wollen X Milliarden investieren, aber dann wollen wir von euch auch die Garantie haben, dass wir das Geld auch zurückverdienen können und nicht dazu gezwungen werden, alle anderen in unsere Netze reinzulassen. Also das ist eine Art der Förderung.
Aber das ist ja quasi das Gegenteil von dem, was gerade hier in breiter Runde gefordert wird. Weil das diskriminierungsfrei ist, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, genau dieses Reinlassen ins Netz.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist das, was dann auf der Netzebene passiert. Aber vorher im politischen Raum, wo eben über sowas verhandelt wird und zwar tagtäglich, läuft das eben auf so einer Ebene ab.
Also ich sehe ja ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen schwarz für meinen Gigabit-Anschluss. Bei mir zu Hause, ich würde jetzt gerne noch eine sozusagen kurze Abschlussrunde machen. Und ihr könnt entweder sozusagen mir sagen, was ich jetzt tun kann, damit ich vielleicht doch meinen Gigabit kriege. Oder mir eine realistische Einschätzung geben, wie lange das in Deutschland noch dauern wird. Bis es sozusagen, bis es nicht mehr die Ausnahme ist, dass es sowas gibt.
Das einfachste ist, du ziehst um in ein Land, wo es das gibt. Das gibt wahrscheinlich auch am schnellsten. Ich hab gehört, die Schweiz ist sehr schön. Ansonsten wahrscheinlich wirklich politisch aktiv werden, Druck aufbauen und Informationen weitergeben, wie immer leider. Wir haben in Deutschland leider einen sehr, sehr, sehr starken Robiismus in dem Bereich.
Nochmal das Worst-Case-Szenario. Okay, wir haben das Vectoring, wir haben das VDSL2. Aber trotzdem werden wir irgendwann an den Punkt kommen, wo das dann nicht mehr reicht. Was ist das Worst-Case-Szenario, wann wir mit Glasfaserausbau anfangen, weil es nicht mehr anders geht?
60 Monate.
60, what is it, sir?
Abschreibungszeit des Equipments, was jetzt verbaut wird.
Naja, aber es ist ja so, ich habe damals, als die 3D-Fernseher zum ersten Mal vorgeführt wurden, dann habe ich gesagt, wann kommt die denn? Dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr? So, nee, die werden erst mal die ganzen HD-Fernseher sozusagen den Markt voll machen. Erst wenn die dann HD-Fernseher hat, dann werden die 3D-Fernseher kommen. Analog, klar, also nach dem jetzt hingeklickt, dann könnten sie Glasfaser bauen. Aber es gibt vielleicht noch Zwischenstufen, was sie...
Herr DVB-T haben sie jetzt auch ausgemacht, nachdem das abgeschrieben war.
Also in 60 Monaten kriegen wir dann Glasfaser.
Der andere Tipp ist einfach mal zu gucken, wo Fördergelder fließen und sich vielleicht mal so ein kleines Dorf aussuchen, was jetzt ein Glasfaserausbau bekommt.
Ich möchte nicht umziehen, herrgott. Kann auch nicht so schwer sein.
Das ist schöner, da gibt es Kühe.
Und Bauernhöfe.
Allerletzte Frage, die ich an euch habe ist, und da gehen wir nochmal an Anfang zurück. Ihr habt ja gesagt, sind Symmetrisches ganz richtig. Gigabit will ich nicht nur als Download haben, sondern auch als Upload. Jetzt hast du gesagt, man kann seinen eigenen Fileserver betreiben, also quasi die Fotos nicht mehr zu Flickr oder sonst wo hochladen, sondern halt am eigenen Rechner. Aber habt ihr noch so andere Beispiele, was da noch möglich wäre, wenn wir alle breitbandiges, symmetrisches Internet zu Hause hätten?
Nehmen wir einfach mal so eine Großfamilie. Man hat drei Generationen und man kommt von einem Familienurlaub zurück und will all seinen Lieben eigentlich zeigen, was man da gemacht hat. Dann müsste man heute, damit alle das sehen können, entweder mit den USB-Sticks rumfahren oder ein paar Posts verschicken oder man müsste die Dinge in die Cloud laden oder an irgendwelche anderen Firmen drauf Zugriff haben, könnten und die dann wiederum für was auch immer das nutzen. Wir hatten es ja zweimal in den Nachrichten, was man damit machen kann. Wenn man jetzt so einen Breitbandanschluss hätte, dann könnte man auch bei der Oma so eine kleine Kiste hinstellen, mit einer Festplatte drin oder auch ohne und die könnten direkt zugreifen auf die Daten. Das heißt, man könnte seine eigene Familien-Cloud aufbauen, in dem Augenblick, wo man mehr Bandbreite auch ins Netz hat.
Aber das hat der Verhinten nicht mal so weit gehen.
Was gibt es denn noch?
Wir haben diese ganzen VR-Brillen-Geschichten. Es gibt aktuell halt keine Technik, die das benutzt, weil wir haben keine Bandbreite. Wer spricht denn dagegen, dass ich eine 3D-Kamera bei mir zu Hause habe und damit ein Familientreffen mit so einer VR-Brille mache? Und dann können halt Leute, die sonst wo sitzen, das Gefühl bekommen, dass sie bei mir im Wohnzimmer sitzen und sich mit mir unterhalten. Diese Anwendung würde momentan gar nicht funktionieren, weil ich diese Datenmengen gar nicht zu den anderen Leuten bekommen aus meinem Wohnzimmer.
Na gut, wir haben also heute gelernt, wir wollen mehr Internet, aber wir werden es nicht bekommen. Ich beschließe die Sendung damit. Bedanke und verabschiede mich herzlich von Johannes, Stefan, Filz und Mutags. Tschüssi. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.